So you want to get into data science? Right? Well,
you're in luck because I work as a data scientist at untitled
company. Wait,
I work as a data science add untitled company.
Hey guys. Welcome.
Welcome to another episode of Joe Dennis.
Welcome.
Oh my.
Hey guys. Welcome to another episode of gentleman tech.
Now you might be wondering why am I in my room? Well,
that's just how things are going to be from here on out. So quick,
a little update. Um, I had to remove my day in the life video,
uh, you know, the one that got me, most of my views, uh,
I had to take it down because I violated some policies.
So that's why it's gone.
But today we're going to be talking about something different.
We're going to be talking about how to get a data science job at a, you know,
a large company like Friendster or MySpace, something like that. First of all,
what is data science? Because I have a feeling,
a lot of people have misconceptions about data science. So if you do,
I would suggest you to check this video I made with, um, engineering truth.
So yeah,
check that out and hopefully it'll give you an understanding of what data
science actually is or what my role is. All right.
So let's get to it to the five tips on how to land a data science job.
Number one, tip, do an internship and have a technical degree.
How I got my first hands-on experience on data science was my internship.
And I did my internship in a large untitled company. And, um,
how I got that internship was, uh,
was I just had a few software engineering background, which you can see, uh,
you could see my other internships on a previous videos, but yeah,
I had a few internships that software engineering and my degree is in CS.
I never touched data science before. So that's the thing.
So the easiest way is to get an internship and then usually they will give you a
full-time offer right after. So here are some examples of good degrees to have,
uh, CS, uh, software engineering, uh, economics, statistics, math,
uh, just engineering in general, like system engineering, uh,
maybe even environmental engineering,
just anything with the word engineering in it. They would, you know,
demonize technical and they will give you an interview. All right,
second tip learn SQL or SQL. I'm not sure.
Um, so when you're going to start your work as a data scientist,
no matter where it is, you're always going to have to write SQL.
Cause you got to get the data somehow,
no matter how fancy your Python is and stuff like that in the end,
usually most companies set up their infrastructure so that you query data using
SQL. Why? Because it's an easy language and even like analysts or like business
intelligence people they use SQL. So now you'll probably have to use SQL too,
because it's just easier for them.
And then because they set up the infrastructure like that,
you'll have to use that too.
And you also should learn SQL because all of the interviews I got
that was related to data science, I had a secret question.
Let me show you an example of question.
So I found this take-home exam and I will change it a little bit so
that the large company, which is not the original untitled large company,
but another large company that might or might not be related to transportation
gave me this take-home exam. So I'm going to whip it out. So for example,
what they would do is they would give you a schema and they will give you a
schema. For example, you see ID, client ID, driver, ID, city ID, client rating,
driver rating, and stuff like that.
And then the question would be something like for each of the cities, uh,
San Francisco and Los Angeles calculate 90th percentile
difference between actual and predicted ETA for all completed trip within the
last 30 days. And then when you do is you have to write queries for that. Yeah.
Uh, I'm not going to go through the answer, but you should,
that would give you an idea of what kind of query you should run.
Tip number three, learn about success metrics and tracking metrics.
That is very, very important.
And it's kind of hard to learn because it's more about product sense.
So why is it important? It's important because when you become a data scientist,
you will be the extrovert on your team on data, right?
So imagine if your team is like at McDonald's and you know,
you're domain data scientists,
then you're the one that will know where everything comes from.
Like all the data sources and also what to measure for success,
because you're going to be the one that the PMs asks you like, okay,
how do we know we're doing a good job?
How do we know that the introduction of these new hamburgers that they're
actually successful and making McDonald's a better place for people? You know,
sometimes it's easy, sometimes a lot harder to define the success metrics.
I'll give you an example, taking from the same take-home exam.
So imagine if the YouTube creator app, uh,
in case you don't know what the YouTube creator app, it's a,
it's an app for YouTube creators like myself. And when you click on it,
you could see like how many views are getting, you know, and how many, uh,
watch time and like what video is performing a lot,
what comments you're getting is basically a tool for creators like myself.
So that's basically what the YouTube creator app is.
So imagine that YouTube creator app is being redesigned, you know,
under adding CTR metrics or ironing, a better interfaces. And they have like a,
I don't know, just better user interface and like a whole facelift.
How do you know that the redesign was successful and what are the success
metrics and the tracking metrics. All right.
Let me talk to you about the difference between success metrics and tracking
metrics. Success metrics is usually the one that the whole team cares about.
You know, they're always seeing growth, usually at a startup.
It would be like how many active users you have, for example, not vine.com.
Bondo to startup can not find.com or you can share 6.1 second videos.
So imagine not vine.com. I would care about how many active users,
like on a daily basis, how many unique people actually open the app? You know,
I would care about it.
That would be my success metrics because that's the main thing I care about for
now. And yeah, and then tracking metrics. I want to make sure, you know,
that they're actually, you know,
one real people or two having a good time on my app.
So what are the tracking metrics? So that would be, for example,
let's think about it. Um, I want to know if they're actually watching a lot of,
you know, videos,
so tracking metrics can be washed time per active user and then,
or maybe just watch time in general. And then another thing can be like,
how many videos are they watching? You know,
I want to make sure that the internet just opening the app and doing nothing.
And then also let's see another tracking metrics would be, you know, how many,
uh, how many like force quit do they have? Why do I care about that?
Because I want to make sure I want to track the negative stuff too. Like,
are my, like, are my apps being a buggy? Like if they are,
and it keep force quitting,
then maybe the reason why they spend so much time on the app is because it's
really buggy. Right?
So I have to track these things to make sure that it's not buggy. Basically.
You want your metrics to be non cheatable and represents success on your
company. And then the next question, after asking,
like how would you define your success metrics? It would be, how do you test it?
Okay. So here's one thing that you need to know.
You need to know about AB tests.
You need to know about control groups and experimental groups and like how many
people do you need in them enough. So that, uh, enough,
so that's statistically significant that you could see the differences,
but also to reduce risk of having a product that you launch. Right?
Because imagine if you're the, the, the launch of the new product,
or like a feature that you built on not fine.com is incredibly.
You don't want everyone,
you don't want the whole 50% of your users to be exposed to that experiment.
Right? So you have to think about ways to, uh, to make sure you don't risk that,
but also to get enough information that's statistically significant, all right,
tip number four,
learn I Python R Tableau or Excel or whatever to manipulate,
visualize and interpret that Utah. So why do you need to know all of this? Uh,
to be honest, in my personal opinion,
a lot of people like to use I Python R because they actually look really,
you know, uh, technical and coding intensive, but, you know, honestly,
I see a lot of good data. Science only use Excel, right?
They just grabbed the data using sequel, they manipulate it using SQL,
and then they just put an Excel to visualize things because the impact is not
how technical you are,
but how well you communicate those findings and how well translate into product
recommendations. Now I'll talk about communication later.
Why do you need to learn all of these? Because you know,
you have to manipulate data sometimes sequel,
can't cut it and you need to visualize the data because you need to communicate
them later. So, so imagine you have a lot of data and your company, let's see,
let's go back to McDonald's. So what do you do? You do an exploratory analysis.
So imagine you're McDonald's and you have bunch of data about your sandwiches or
your hamburgers and stuff like that. So what, the first thing you can do,
you could, you know, use it to download all the data, manipulate them,
group them by like, you know, hamburgers or day of the week and stuff like that.
And you get discover a lot of things using that. And how would you do it?
You would use either Tableau, Excel, R or Python to manipulate things, right?
Because you want to answer your questions, like, all right,
which day of the week, um, we have the most sales and now which hamburgers,
uh, have, you know, which hamburgers are the most popular,
but then you could also say like,
which hamburgers actually have the highest profit margin plus, you know,
sales like, so which one gives you more revenue, you know, and stuff like that.
And then which ones are actually losing money?
Because apparently when I worked there, uh, ice cream,
every time they sell ice cream,
they were actually losing money because employees didn't know how to stop
putting ice cream. So they filled it up too much.
So they try to teach us how to put ice cream,
but only put around it and leave a big void in the middle so that they save more
ice cream. I never did that because I cared about my customers.
So I want them to have the best ice cream ever, even if McDonald's losing money,
just saying, so this is why you have to learn, uh,
stuff like I Python R and stuff like that. Yeah. Honestly,
it doesn't matter which one, just as long as you're fast and you're correct at,
you know, creating these, uh, visualizations. So yeah.
So Indiana use any of these technologies to show your results,
to interpret them. And yeah. So that's why you need them. All right.
Number five, you have to learn to communicate really,
really well because the whole point of a data scientist is to communicate their
findings, right? Because if you don't communicate your findings,
no one will know. And if no one will know, it's not going to,
it's not going to flourish into anything.
It's not going to forge into any products, learn how to do public speaking,
you know, because they're going to be doing a lot of presentations.
You're going to be talking to a lot of people.
Also a lot of cross functional partners,
a lot of people like PM's engineers and all that.
You're going to be talking to them all the time and you'll be presenting to
them,
learn how to write better because you can't be presenting to everyone in the
company, but, you know,
whatever you found is valuable for maybe for another team.
So how do you do that? You write about it and you know, you write PowerPoints.
You are, you read an article within your company.
You write a post when email that's pretty important too, because like, um,
writing is a very good medium to reach as many people as possible,
especially at work, learn how to make interesting PowerPoints because, uh,
when you're going to be presenting to people or when you're going to be
presenting, you know, uh, your, your article,
you want to have graphs and stuff like that. And then you won't,
you don't want it to make it boring.
You want it to make it obvious what they're looking at. I mean, that's all,
I see a lot of data scientists.
They have like graphs with like a ton of like fancy crap,
but I can interpret it.
Like I look at it and there's a ton of bars and like colors and stuff like that.
But what am I supposed to look at, dude, I don't have attention span, you know?
And just like a video creator you need to,
we need to get your attention within the five seconds.
That's the same thing with work. If people don't want to read your,
you're not going to have any value added to them because they didn't read your
post. So make sure that when you present a graph,
that it tells exactly what you're supposed to tell. So enough information,
and it's obvious what you're trying to say, and it proves their thesis.
So we have the same, actually. I just say that,
I don't think it's actually a saying, but here's the thing.
If you made an interesting analysis, but no one is there to read your analysis.
Did you really make an analysis? Hmm. Food for thought,
but yeah. And then bonus, uh, last one, uh, learn predictive modeling.
So this is not super required because, um,
it's funny because most people they optimize on this learn predictive modeling,
whenever do think data science,
because they think data science is really related to like forecasting or like
finance, finance. It would be pretty important because the whole goal of your,
of your job is to make more money. And how do you make more money?
You predict the future. So, so that you can capitalize on it,
but for us as like a product data scientists, uh, predictive modeling,
isn't that important, but it's good to know.
And it makes you a little bit cooler. So, yeah.
So it might be useful when you're like forecasting goals and stuff like that,
or when you want to build recommendation systems on your product,
but it's not super important, but it adds credibility. And also, you know,
so that you can tell your friends, I, you do modeling. Ooh. All right. So yeah.
So that's about it. That's five tips on how to land a data science shop at an
untitled large company. And, uh, yeah, I hope, I hope that was useful.
I hope that was great. Uh,
this is pretty short because I don't want to go through the details of it,
but if you have any questions, um, you know,
comment down below and I'll try to answer it or I'll try and make another video
later on. So yeah. So don't forget to like this video,
if it added value to your life and also subscribe if you like my videos and, uh,
yeah. Peace out. Thanks for watching.